so between the two of you who is
actually the bigger like wizarding world
like potterhead I think we're both
pretty bots ezreal and the two of us
probably is so well I mean other than
Ezzor because we all know that he's the
the biggest fan who going into the
process the second movie actually has
gotten closest to being much more of a
Harry Potter fans you guys dive into it
even more going into this one I mean I
grew up with the books I like the older
films but diving into this film that was
really important for me to kind of focus
just on my character on who she is and
trying to make her as human as possible
and I think when I start to get caught
up in the world and how big it is and
what it means to people it gives me a
little bit of anxiety so I really try to
focus on the humanity of of Lita super
exciting at the beginning and then you
realize that you can't keep that
excitement because that would stop you
from exactly seeing its concentrate on
your your cog in the system and the
bigger picture you can't be giddy in
every scene these people great actors
yeah did I state your claim yeah a
little bit yeah
it's be in the moment be in the moment
yeah which would be my but we all know
the fandom is so real which can be a
double-edged sword - they're like the
majority of people are super excited but
then there are some people that before
you even seeing the film will have like
negative comments or be bashing it just
from like really hey you know I'm gonna
hate so what's the reaction to that like
how do you deal with that - uh dude do
you think stop drinking that haterade
yeah let's get in it
even if it's on the deal tip 1 so not
only do you get to remain this legendary
franchise you get to work with Jude Law
who is like sexy Dumbledore he's sexy
Jude Law which turns into sexy
Dumbledore I just love to do a little
selection we will have two dudes like
the nicest a brother man
yeah yeah being being on set with them
or being in seen with him is it I mean
we just talked about the idea of not
being giddy about being a Harry Potter
fan you got a yeah I keep in control
when you're would you lots you right
it's much no everyone like you know
across the board no lifes believe the do
believe Joe David David
Zoe Eddie Ezra Johnny
Allison Catherine if you guys could I
know there's no talk of petronas in this
so far in a space but if you could give
each other like a Patronus like what do
you think his would be only thing hers
would be well actually I got I bought I
did the test you did the test I got this
year
you got the deer is that gonna stay nice
I'd say I'd say tell me Jake you're on
Thank You Jay yeah Jay I can't either
yeah I'm ENGLISH I can't speak